"Minneapolis on fire."
"This is getting serious."
"Oh, oh, oh my goodness."
You watch the TV news...
"We've got a little bit of a fire
breaking out on the left here."
...and you're like, oh my goodness, all the protests are riots.
"...vandalizing..."
"Fires have been started..."
"Things got out of control..."
We're not gonna pay attention to the protesters in a city
that has been wracked by this violence...
"No justice, no peace!"
...who are marching peacefully,
and chanting names.
"George Floyd, George Floyd, George Floyd..."
Which is going to get more
attention? A group of 35 people standing,
chanting names, singing songs, doing the
Cupid Shuffle, as I saw one group of protesters doing,
or, five people on the
ground bleeding and screaming and crying
and throwing rocks?
Our press is driven
by eyeballs, and attention, and clicks,
and advertising, and passion, and raising
the anxiety of viewers.
Dramatic images are money.
They keep eyeballs on the
screen. So they will constantly show action.
You need to understand the
limitations of those visuals.
I'm a college professor.
My doctorate is in political science, I teach in a journalism department.
I would say, across
the board, the coverage has not been very good.
It's passing, but it's not very good.
And the reason it's not very good is because
there are not enough conversations about
the roots of these protests.
What they are showing you is what is happening right now on the ground.
What those
visuals cannot tell you
is the entire historical context that has led to that
scene on the ground.
And one thing that a lot of mainstream media doesn't do well is give you that full context.
You can't untangle this moment from
where we are, just in this year.
Starting with February, with the coronavirus...
Ahmaud Arbery's lynching,
having people in shelter in place,
having people become
angry that they are in shelter in place orders,
having the economy
significantly slow down.
There are so many events, just since January,
that led
up to this moment.
Not to mention the hundreds of years before that.
This becomes a very complicated story.
"Come to me right now. This woman just got tased."
Who is to blame for the violence?
It is crazy that when we talk about
destruction of property,
that the presumption is that the unarmed people
who are protesting
are more likely to cause property destruction
than the
paramilitary cops who are showing up.
Because tear gas canisters are really
hot, flash bombs can start fires,
tear gas leads people to run and break through
windows in order to hide and get help.
I'm not saying the police are intending
to cause damage.
But if you're randomly shooting out tear gas, it's gonna end up in the back alley,
with a pile of newspapers and some garbage.
Does that mean that there aren't protesters who engage in destruction?
Of course there
are.
To say that that all this is turning into looters
is like saying
everybody at the party is a drunk driver.
No.
Some people will leave and cause
problems.
But you can't say everybody at the party is the worst-behaving person.
I think one thing that we actually don't do well,
and don't quite understand, is
anti-blackness, and how it works in our society,
how it is in our language,
and how it is used by mainstream media.
We have spent the last month watching
protests who want the country to open up,
and we saw images of these people
screaming, and yelling, and spitting on
police officers, who were plainclothes
officers.
They weren't in riot gear. They weren't in masks.
Now we see protests based on violence and death.
And we see peaceful
protesters come out.
But suddenly, the cops come out in riot gear,
and everything looks like some sort of violent takeover in some 80s post-apocalyptic film.
What I'm reminded of are photos in New Orleans
of white people leaving stores with food,
and the headline being, this is how people are surviving.
And black folks leaving the store with food, and calling them looters.
This is about a community that is
treated differently by the police in our country.
Just consuming the news right
now in the next five days
is not going to give you a good understanding as to
why this is happening.
The emails I get, where people say,
Well, I was in favor of the protesters,
and then they turned violent, and it's a
problem.
Well, why are you more offended by people being violent, in response to state-sponsored violence,
than you are by the initial act that caused everything?